Okay,
what you're about to experience is
shocking for them,
a German term for taking pleasure in
someone else's misfortune.
Let's back up a bit.
There's a cottage industry around
shopping online.
It's why fail videos get tens of
millions of views,
and it's why there's so much fun to
watch.
Fail compilations are an evolution of
things like jackass and the America's
funniest home video format,
which is really just a nonfiction
version of the slapstick comedy that you
see in the three stooges or Charlie
Chaplin movies where Shakespeare's
comedies going all the way back probably
to the origin of laughter itself.
Why do we feel this way?
What makes us enjoy the pain of others?
It comes down to identity and self
esteem.
Human society is defined by competition
and comparison.
When you see someone fail,
your psyche is rewarded with a little
boost.
The feeling that you're better off than
they are shopping for to is particularly
strong wind.
The failure in question is arrogant or
deserving or even just to successful.
That's why we delight when celebrities
fall from grace.
It's why the downfall of super high
achievers like tiger woods generates so
much media attention in societies.
These feelings extend to our groups.
The more we identify with our Ingroup,
like our favorite sports team,
for example,
the more susceptible we are to shot in
Florida.
When a rival team loses.
Now in the realm of sports and people
falling off,
rope swings,
feelings of shot and Florida are natural
and innocent.
Self esteem is not a steady thing.
Fluctuates and if it fail,
compilation makes you laugh.
Why not?
Were shot in Florida,
I think becomes poisonous is in the
universe of politics.
I mean if Shoutin,
Florida is a feature of ingroups and
outgroups in competition,
it should be no surprise that it festers
in our political parties where the
victory of one side almost always means
a defeat of the other and studies on
Shoutin,
Florida in politics bear this out.
Intensity of party affiliation strongly
predicts whether events produce shot in
Florida in their members when the
Republican party missteps or one of its
members commits a gaffe.
Democrats report feelings of shopping
for them and vice versa.
What complicates things is that politics
involves the wellbeing and the suffering
of millions of people.
The failure of your opponent group can
often spell objectively bad consequences
for everybody,
and yet the most disturbing finding of
studies on Shodan 40 to in politics is
that even in these cases,
people report shouting for that as long
as their opponents lose out.
Scary as that is,
you can take solace in the fact that
most people understand that these
feelings are socially inappropriate,
which is why they're felt that not
really spoken about studies.
Bear this out to those who report
feelings of Shodan for at objectively
bad news like an economic downturn
hurting the opposing party are also
deeply ambivalent about just having that
emotion or at least they to be.
All I did is point out the fact that on
the cover of the national enquirer,
there's a picture of him and crazy Lee
Harvey Oswald having breakfast now.
10 never denied that it was his father.
One of the things that troubled me about
the 2016 election was the presence of
Shodan Freida among Democrats and
opponents of Donald Trump.
He seemed to free people up somehow,
and I think it's because ambivalence
about shotgun Florida in politics is a
result of the fact that on some level we
believe our opponent group is genuinely
trying to help.
We're just going about it the wrong way.
Trump,
on the other hand is so cartoonish,
so nakedly selfserving that any
reservations people might have about
basking in his blunders just evaporated.
Donald trump is the perfect figure for
Shotgun Florida.
He checks every box arrogant,
successful,
deserving.
What's more,
he openly participates in it himself.
It's Rubio,
right?
I offered the opportunity for guilt free
shot in Florida,
and this is what troubles me because it
was natural for trump supporters to take
pleasure in his candidacy,
but what I saw all around me was his
opponents feeling the same way.
For many,
it was just as enjoyable as watching a
fail compilation video.
Seeing him make appalling comment after
appalling common at the start when he
was a joke,
there seemed to be a little harm and
expressing the shotgun Florida,
but there was an effect because the news
media registered this feeling as
interest and as a result gave an
enormously lopsided amount of media
coverage to his campaign,
which may trump the focus of everything.
It may be the first time in US history
that collective shoutin Florida
influenced a political outcome,
and that's not a joke at all.
Right now we're living through an
intoxicating mixture of entertainment,
politics,
journalism,
and shot in Florida.
It's a mixture that is unbelievably
great for the news media and as trump is
embroiled in the Russia investigation,
the news media is showing its best side,
but it's worth site two with each new
revelation,
each new bombshell report the Shazam for
you to become stronger,
and that incentive is impossible for
media executives to resist.
If trump goes down,
it'll be met with alation from certain
sectors of the public and who knows he
may deserve it,
but whatever happens with his presidency
shot in Freud,
it is a drug that we ought to keep in
check because like any drug,
a growing tolerance will eventually mean
a growing desire for more of it more
often,
and that's not a force we want power in
our politics.
Everybody.
Thank you so much for watching.
I've been thinking about this for awhile
now,
so it was great to sort of get it off my
chest.
This episode was brought to you by
squarespace.
If you want to make a website and you
want it to be a really easy process,
squarespace has some beautiful award
winning designer templates to choose
from.
That makes the process really simple.
It's got 24 hour customer service,
no upgrades,
nothing to install,
no patches ever,
and picking your domain name is really
easy.
You can start your free
trial@squarespace.com,
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
If you want to make a website,
use squarespace.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next time.